thank you I wouldn't mind doing a
residency in Vegas
damn little Ralphie that's what they
would call it oh my god what you did was
just like Ralphie May that was the name
of it oh man you looked just like
wrapped like you were that easy
dude I feel guilty now I know that I had
nothing to do with this but me and him
were on a cruise ship right before he
passed like a few months for a pouch
does he sleep in the middle of a shake
he has sleep in the middle of a cruise
ship six hundred pounds or five hundred
pounds you couldn't sleep on a side of
the cruise ship could you he was
sleeping a lot that trip he wasn't
getting up and doing much huh and and I
went we went to his room once a day and
when we go in there and smoke a joint in
his room and and what he's just laying
in bed the whole time he was laying in
bed a lot he'd get up and move around I
mean I mean I'm I'm not I'm definitely
not speaking ill of the dead but anyone
was on that ship would agree he'd move
around like probably two out of the
seven days we were there he'd get up and
do stuff and he not often not often was
he moving around and when you say like
like cuz I've never been around anybody
that has had that much of a you know an
impairment that wasn't like you know I
had a friend that didn't have any legs
and he didn't do that much and then I
had another lady that I think was just
lazy when I was growing up you know and
she also was taking care of a kid a
black child you know and both her and
her husband were white and they were
pretending like it was their child to
everybody even though the lady that
swept had his school bus was black miss
tilly brilliant
it was obviously her child and we'd go
over there and it was the weirdest thing
you'd like this our son boogie and it
would be like dude they had him dressed
up like a little cowboy and [ __ ] like to
make him just see me wider dude
I no joke I revert this little boogie
heat up on these red boots and he would
do this little [ __ ] dance by the door
when you went in and it was like what
like even I know that you can't get a
black kid out of two white people no
matter how hard you try I love that name
boogie do you know there's a I met a
football player in a place called the
chatterbox one time
MacFarlane bulgar MacFarlane last song
one time at the airport dear now I
wanted to talk about so Miss Borland
they were like those are my friend
booger you know he got the nickname no
cuz he would hit people so hard that
they'd have to [ __ ] pick him out of
their nose are you serious I did not
know these always have boogers
the only other booger I met was Revenge
of the Nerds yes hair pie and now you
imagine now but I hit you so hard you
have to pick me out of your [ __ ] McKim
introduced me to him at the Chatterbox
in Tampa
when I was high as [ __ ] and she's like
hey this is my friend I was like hey man
how you doing he's a big guy played at
LSU yeah and he was like it's just like
hey how you doing I'm burnt he goes I'm
booger and I went I could not stop
[ __ ] laughing and I and no one else
was laughing because he was a buck at
the time yeah everyone knew booger
McFarlane so let's go on so I want to
hear more about that Ralphie mouse this
thing yeah so I don't know what I'm
saying to be in Vegas so we were all
hanging out oh yeah you guys were on the
cruise ship and I said that I hadn't
heard many people that couldn't move
around that much
he oddly enough he is the reason I
called this special secret on the
Netflix special because he we were all
hanging out and he was like I got off
for the residency in Vegas I was like
man I was like roughly I think that's
the best thing for you in my opinion you
go you get in Vegas you get healthy you
don't have to fly you don't have to
travel I guess traveling was the thing
keeping him healthy because he was
moving around they had to get him right
up and out but he didn't think of that
huh you have to get up and go to the to
the bus you have to get up at the gas
station maybe go get a drink you know do
stuff you have to get up and pay for gas
you have together
there's things he had to do I guess but
I was like go to Vegas dude because in
my head I go go to Vegas get healthy get
it get involved some UFC gym out there
yeah where they're like you know maybe
it's not I don't know but like they're
fans of Rogen's pockets they know who I
am and the let me work out or like some
guy keeps an eye on me and it's like
make sure I'm doing something healthy
yeah and then go in like go play golf
wants it
I do a show don't drink cuz you can just
come home yeah I'll be great for me and
I told him I was like dude do it and so
then we did one show I gotta be dead
honest who probably the funniest I've
ever seen him in my entire life he had a
joke about have a mediocre dick you ever
heard this and he goes out he goes now
you go out there talking about having a
big dick
I got mediocre dick no one wants big
dick ladies you don't want big dick
leaving your [ __ ] like a horse reaching
for a sugar tube like he did nine of
those do nine of those and I'm [ __ ]
dying laughing you don't want big
because at nine different tags he was so
good at that of doing those nine
different tags and then I went up after
him and I was buzzed already I was
already drunk and and I never get but it
was like a cruise ship I'm cow head
screws counter screws I gotten high with
my ax
yeah he's a sweetheart I got hired with
Ralphie and the things I found funny
were just secrets that I was gonna say
on stage and then Ralph - Ralph Ian cow
heads so they could just and just be
like secrets and like I was and I just
first joke was like secret time I got a
shower dry my [ __ ] in the bed and
Ralphie lost it and he's like he does do
that [ __ ] don't you and I was like yeah
and he goes more secrets player so I
just kept telling secrets like secret
times name is special few times name is
special and I got off stage in Ralphie's
like that's the funniest [ __ ] I've ever
heard you say he goes just tell secrets
just tell seek oh you kept going
tell what's no true it's like you you
like yeah there's Sonny you like toms
secret I love telling secrets like when
I go like the perfect example is like
when I go seek your time I only had sex
with six people and then I go [ __ ] it's
like it's women right like it's you just
um and and I also feel like if you keeps
like and that's the other part is I talk
[ __ ] about my family so I don't want
them seeing it
sorry that's other part of the secret
time but it Ralphie was like he all
night we went to dinner that night at
the Italian restaurant on the boat and
he was like he kept going tell me more
secrets Bert tell me more secrets and I
just was like and when you're open up
yeah and you and you're like I was
telling them everything I got the clap
in college then why yeah and then I just
tell them the story and they were
laughing and I was like oh yeah I guess
that's kind of what I do on stage is
just tell a secret and then my kids dumb
as [ __ ] and I tell the story yeah so
yeah so the but Ralph
had to do with me did you enjoy that
clip well you really would have enjoyed
it if he was watching on a TCL TV TCL is
America's fastest-growing TV brand it's
so fast it's the Carl Lewis of
television brands it's that Florence
Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com